[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Welcome
to this episode
of "VME End to End," where
you have a VM enthusiast
and a former VM skeptic--
so now, you have two VM
enthusiasts-- talking
about all things VM related.
Brian, welcome to the show.
I'm super excited and a little
bashful to have you here today.
BRAIN DORSEY: Likewise.
So you're convinced?
Sweet.
CARTER MORGAN: You
have convinced me.
You know what?
Cloud VMs seem relevant.
They seem useful.
They seem a lot of fun.
So I guess what I want to
know is, how do I get started?
Do I have to travel
back in time?
Find a dusty manual
somewhere, blow it off,
look up instructions?
If I want to use
this, where do I go?
What do I do?
BRAIN DORSEY: Come on, man.
We're in the cloud now.
So it's a web world, so I
think a great place to start
is on the web.
So there's a Cloud console
at cloud.google.com
that is a website that you
can manage all the cloud,
and in there, Compute Engine.
So I think it's a really good
place to see what's possible
and to explore, learn, get
some visualizations on what's
going on with the machines.
CARTER MORGAN: And
there is a command line,
though, if someone like
me is a little more--
BRAIN DORSEY: Oh, yeah.
CARTER MORGAN: Just checking.
Tell me about it.
BRAIN DORSEY: I
know you want to go
for efficiency and
automation and the like,
there's definitely
a command line,
and it uses the same
API behind the scenes.
CARTER MORGAN: Do they interact
with each other at all,
or are they just two separate
tools with the same API?
BRAIN DORSEY: So they're
primarily separate tools,
but there's some neat
bootstrapping stuff.
One high level is
there's actually
a command line embedded in the
web UI, so you can hit a button
and get a command
line interface off
of, actually, a little
VM that we run for you.
But in addition to that, any
of the Compute Engine pages
you're on, when you go
to, say, create a new VM--
fill out a bunch of things,
make a bunch of decisions,
if you scroll to
the bottom, there's
a link to get the exact
GCloud syntax that
would do the same thing as
you'd just set up in the web.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh,
that's very cool.
Then you could go into
that web shell and use it.
All right, I can see--
BRAIN DORSEY: Copy-paste, go.
CARTER MORGAN: --how that
could be useful-- very useful.
One of the things
I'm wondering about
is, I come from,
again, Container World,
and I'm used to using
something like Docker, where
I can declaratively
say, this is what
I want my image to look like.
I want it to have this layer.
I want it to have
this set of tooling.
Is there anything like
that for VMs or Google VMs?
BRAIN DORSEY: Absolutely,
and in particular,
people use a lot of
Terraform for that.
But I want to take a
step back [INAUDIBLE]
some of the things people
do on VMs are manual.
And for a long-lived
VM, a manual
setup and take some backups,
that is a reasonable thing
to do for a one-off.
But as soon as you start
having multiple copies of that
or more complex setup, you
start wanting automation.
So there are multiple
different tools
that use the same APIs to
create VMs and configure
the networking and the like.
In particular, Terraform
is very, very common.
I think it's also worth checking
out Pulumi, and both of those
will let you set
up a configuration,
declare how you want things
to look, and push that out.
And part of the reason I
think this is so important--
so it's important
for production to be
able to make things consistent.
But in addition to that,
testing is really hard.
Almost nobody can afford to run
a full test environment that's
the size of production.
And in physical machines, it,
as far as I know, almost never
happens.
But if you have
things automated,
you can run a test of a
smaller number of machines
or the same number of machines
for a shorter amount of time
for way less money.
You're going to be talking 1%
or parts of a percent of what
it costs to run a production
and do a completely
valid test in the
same environment using
the same tools.
So that's really powerful.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh, wow,
that's really cool.
And I've actually seen that
pattern a lot in Kubernetes.
I talk about Kubernetes a lot
because that's my context.
But in Kubernetes,
you have this ability
to automate what happens
when you do certain actions.
So if I wanted to
release some code
and have it go to a
small staging area
before it went out fully to
production, you could do that.
And what I'm hearing--
tell me if I'm
wrong here, but it
sounds like you can
do that same thing,
but on a different scale.
You might be able to do
that with your entire cloud
infrastructure using some of the
tooling you were talking about.
BRAIN DORSEY: Yeah,
that's pretty much it.
So people use things
like Terraform
to declare the setup
of things like--
including a Kubernetes
cluster itself, maybe
buckets for storage, maybe
a database, some VMs,
like I mentioned.
And you've got your entire
setup all scripted out
and repeatable and ready to go.
CARTER MORGAN: See,
that's amazing.
And this is one of
the reasons why I'm
happy that I've been convinced.
Something I am
curious about, though,
is, if I already
had my own system--
maybe I switched over
to VMs from on prem.
I have my own way of accessing
my workloads, my VMs,
all of that-- can I still do it?
For instance, if
I had an SSH key,
I was using those
to access my system,
can I still use those
on Google Cloud?
BRAIN DORSEY: Absolutely, and
this gets back to-- the VM
is just a computer, and it's
the most compatible thing
we have in cloud.
So if you can do
it on a computer,
chances are extremely good
you can do it on a VM.
So yes, you can log in with just
user accounts and passwords.
You can log in with SSH keys,
whatever you've normally
been doing.
For SSH keys, we have a couple
of things to help out a bit.
So if you've got automation
you've been using,
you can keep doing
that for managing keys.
We also have a way where
you can push keys up
into the project level and have
them be available on the VMs.
And if you're not running
something like that,
you're already logging into
Google Cloud with a Google
account, so you can
essentially delegate
the rights to log
into a machine,
and then we will create
the SSH keys to make
that happen and make it work.
CARTER MORGAN: Wow, so
there's a lot of power there.
I guess-- so
there's flexibility.
I can use tooling
I already know.
At this point,
there's really nothing
that's leaving me or stopping me
from signing up and using this.
And then I guess I just--
BRAIN DORSEY: Let's do it.
CARTER MORGAN: I don't know.
I set it.
I let it run.
I get the promo.
I win the day.
I drive off in the nice car.
BRAIN DORSEY: [LAUGHS]
It's all done.
CARTER MORGAN: All done.
BRAIN DORSEY: You know
software doesn't work that way.
Things change.
The context around it--
you've got new versions.
Maybe the load changes up
and down, that sort of thing.
Yeah, so things
change, and I think
some of the stuff we've talked
about already helps with that.
So when you talk about
groups of machines
and a managed instance group
getting bigger and smaller,
that helps with load
changes over time.
If we decide to do some
work, like some planned work,
on the host machine,
or the kernel
needs an update or
something like that,
we'll do a live
migration to move
the VM to another
machine with no downtime,
and then do that work.
CARTER MORGAN: That's
transparent to me,
it sounds like.
BRAIN DORSEY:
Exactly, so that'll
help with some changes that need
to happen at the data center
level.
And then when changes
happen to your software,
you'll need to update
it and do versions.
So if you've got a system
you're already using for that,
you can probably
continue doing that.
Another pattern that I
think is pretty common
in cloud, but not other places,
is you build up the whole disk
image, including the software,
and then call that version A.
And then you build
up another disk image
with a new version of
software, call that version B.
And then you can rotate that
into one of these groups
and upgrade that way.
And if something goes
wrong, you can just
go back to the old image.
CARTER MORGAN: This
is why I'm convinced,
because all of these features
that you're talking about
are the features
that I was like,
oh, this is why I
love Kubernetes.
It's so easy to use, it's--
And it's all of them
are in the VM world.
BRAIN DORSEY: So
I strongly believe
that most of the advantages
we get from a cloud native
architecture and
that sort of thing
can be done in VMs on the cloud.
So that brings those
features, those abilities,
to workloads that might be a lot
of work to migrate or require
coordination with another team
that may not exist anymore
or with an external company
or something you can't do.
And so you can get a
bunch of the same benefits
to those workloads as well.
CARTER MORGAN: Wow, so like
I said at the very beginning
of the episode, I'm convinced.
I'm going to go try this.
And if you're watching
this at home, one,
thank you so much
for watching us talk
about VMs for six episodes.
But two, go and try this out.
And then, Brian, you've led the
direction of the conversation
so far.
What we need to talk
about next, where
do you think we should go
from here at this point?
BRAIN DORSEY: So I think we've
hit a pretty good baseline
of fundamentals,
but I think where
we go next really depends
where people want it to go.
So I would love if folks who
watched this long-- again,
thank you--
commented below to
say, here's what
I'd love to learn
more about, what
I'd love to go deeper on, I'd
like to see an example of,
or could you bring in another
expert to talk about something,
those kinds of things.
CARTER MORGAN: So let's do that.
If you're watching this at
home, leave a comment below.
Tell us what we should explore
next, like I don't know,
security or any other
topics, and we'll take a look
and see where we're going
to go in the future.
Thanks again for watching.
That's the end of this
season, and that's the end
of "VME End to End" for now.
Thanks, Brian.
[MUSIC PLAYING]